I have no idea what gave me the confidence to start performing magic shows for money when I was 12. I wasn't especially good. I hadn't been doing it for long. I'm not sure I'd ever been to a magic show. I was a beginner. I was a real beginner. I'd been given one of those magic kits like you give a little kid that they sell at toy stores.
我不知道12岁那年是什么给了我信心去靠表演魔术赚钱。我算不上特别好，也没练多久。我不确定自己在那之前是否看过魔术表演。我只是个初学者，一个真正的初学者。当时我有一个那种在玩具店卖给小孩子的魔术套装。
And then I went to the Baltimore County Public Library on Liberty Road, and found some books on magic in the library. And it blew my mind, these books. These incredible secrets were just like sitting there, right there in the shelves, in the open. Anybody could look at them. I could not understand why anybody was in any of the other aisles. I just felt like, oh, they don't know. They don't know these are here.
后来我去自由路的巴尔的摩县公共图书馆，在馆里找到了一些关于魔术的书。这些书让我大开眼界。那些不可思议的秘密就这样摆在那儿，就在书架上，完全公开。任何人都能看。我不明白为什么还有人去其他过道。我当时就觉得，噢，他们不知道，他们不知道这些书就在这儿。
Before long, I was advertising in the Baltimore Jewish Times. I was booking shows that paid $5. I believe the price was in the ad. These were kids' birthday parties. My dad would drive me. The kids' parents would drive me home.
没过多久，我就在《巴尔的摩犹太时报》上打了广告。我接了一些报酬5美元的演出，我记得价格就写在广告上。那都是些小孩的生日聚会。我爸开车送我去，孩子们的父母则负责送我回家。
After a few months of this, I got a call from a real magician-- like an adult who actually knew what he was doing-- who had noticed somebody undercutting his prices. Who are you, he asked. It wasn't hostile. The magic world in Baltimore was small, and everybody knew everybody. So to have somebody new show up, like, he was just curious.
过了几个月，我接到了一个真正的魔术师的电话——一个真正懂行的成年人，他注意到有人在压价。他问我是谁。这并不是敌意。巴尔的摩的魔术圈很小，大家彼此认识。所以突然冒出个生面孔，他只是感到好奇。
And generous. He let me know that there was a magic store downtown on Charles Street where guys got together. Yogi Magic Mart. On Saturdays, the place would be crowded with any magicians who did not have gigs that day. And they would smoke, and show each other moves. An old guy named Dantini with a huge white beard used to go there. He would give you one of his special coins that was stamped with the words Dantini. He knew Houdini.
而且他很大方。他告诉我市中心查尔斯街有一家魔术店，大家经常在那里聚会，叫“瑜伽魔术市场”。每周六，那里都会挤满当天没演出任务的魔术师。他们会抽烟，互相切磋手法。有个留着大白胡子的老头叫丹蒂尼，以前常去那儿。他会送你一枚印着“丹蒂尼”字样的纪念币。他认识胡迪尼。
When you bought a trick, they took you to this special table in the back room and sat you down. And taught it to you, one on one. As I remember it, this was done with kindness, with helpful tips-- how to tilt your hand, how to turn your body, when to pause for effect. It was exciting to be taken seriously by these men. Sharing these secrets.
当你买一个魔术道具时，他们会带你去后屋的一张特别桌子坐下，手把手教你。据我记忆，他们教的时候很友善，还会给很多实用的建议——比如如何倾斜手部、如何转动身体，以及什么时候该停顿以营造效果。能被这些男人认真对待，并分享这些秘密，真的很让人兴奋。
I did my act from 7th grade through my sophomore year of high school, and so many times it got kind of carved into me. I could have probably performed it word for word and move for move up through my 30s. But now, I'd have a hard time. I still regularly have dreams that I'm supposed to do the act. I had one two weeks ago.
我从七年级一直演到高中二年级，演了这么多次，这些表演仿佛刻在了我脑子里。我当时大概能一字不差、动作不错地演到30多岁。但现在不行了，我肯定记不住了。我至今仍会梦到自己要去表演，两周前还做了这样的梦。
We decided to do this week's radio show about magic when I learned that David Kestenbaum, one of my coworkers here, was also a kid magician. And also played birthday parties for years, starting when he was in fourth grade. And the moment we sat down in the studio to talk about this, like, it only took about a minute to be comparing card moves with the four aces.
当我们得知我的同事大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆小时候也是个小魔术师时，我们决定把这周的电台节目主题定为魔术。他从四年级开始，演了多年的生日派对。我们在录音室刚坐下来聊这个话题，才过了一分钟，我们就开始比较用四张A做出的纸牌戏法了。
Yeah, one of them is face up, right? But you can still go one, two, three, four.
没错，其中一张是面朝上的，对吧？但你依然可以数：一、二、三、四。
All I know is that you're doing a double lift on that first ace.
我只知道你在第一张A上用了双张翻牌手法。
Triple lift.
是三张翻牌。
A triple lift?
三张翻牌？
Then you got to do an Elmsley count, though.
那你还得用埃姆斯利计数法（Elmsley count）。
And very quickly, we just started comparing gear.
很快，我们就开始比较装备了。
Appearing cane. Also disappearing cane.
伸缩手杖。还有消失手杖。
Oh, I had the disappearing cane.
噢，我有消失手杖。
You didn't have the appearing cane?
你没有伸缩手杖吗？
The appearing cane seemed sort of dangerous. Doesn't it sort of s-- have a mechanis--
伸缩手杖看起来有点危险。它是不是……有个机械装置……
Don't say it, don't say it!
别说出来，别说出来！
I won't. But doesn't it have a thing where you can get hurt?
我不说。但它是不是有个地方容易伤到人？
Yes, it can be dangerous. The metal one can be dangerous. I had the plastic one. It was cheaper.
是的，确实有危险。金属的那种可能会伤人。我用的是塑料的，比较便宜。
So when I was 12 years old, I had business cards. I was a 12-year-old with business cards. And mine said on it my name and "Magical Mystifier."
所以12岁那年，我还有名片。我是个有12岁名片的孩子。上面印着我的名字和“魔幻神秘师”。
Well, my business card and said "Master Magician." Which is like, it seems like it's some level like a black belt level or something. You know, like a certified master magician or something. But--
好吧，我的名片上写的是“魔术大师”。这感觉就像是一种等级，比如黑带级别之类的。你知道的，就像什么认证魔术大师。但是……
Yeah. No.
是啊，完全不是那么回事。
Yeah, but it's pretty funny. Like, imagine a 12-year-old kid walks up to you and hands you a business card that says "Master Magician."
没错，但这挺滑稽的。想象一下，一个12岁的孩子走到你面前，递给你一张写着“魔术大师”的名片。
It would be more amazing if they walked up to you and handed you a card that said "Certified Plumber."
如果他们递给你一张写着“认证水管工”的名片，那才叫更惊人。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So David and I were talking about this stuff. And he said this thing that honestly had never crossed my mind ever in my life until he brought it up. We were talking about whether we were any good.
大卫和我聊起这些事时，他说了一件我这辈子从来没想过的事情。当时我们在讨论我们到底水平如何。
I always thought I was fine. And then it occurred to me that maybe the reason I got hired wasn't that I was any good. It was that I was 10 years old. And it was probably adorable to have this little magician come over in his three-piece suit and do tricks for your kid's birthday.
我一直觉得我还行。后来我突然意识到，也许我会被雇佣不是因为我技术好，而是因为我才10岁。那个穿着三件套西装、为你的孩子变魔术的小魔术师，可能看起来真的很可爱。
I feel like this is obviously true. And I'm finding it so upsetting. Because what I realized is, I thought I was the one who was in charge of the situation during the magic show. And I was controlling everybody's minds with my mind and my magickry. And what you're saying is actually that the joke was on me. Like I was the entertainment, but not in a way that I understood.
我觉得这显然是真的，我听了感到非常沮丧。因为我意识到，我一直以为自己在魔术表演中掌控全局，用我的心智和魔术控制了每个人的思维。但你现在的意思是，原来我才是那个被戏弄的对象。我只是个娱乐工具，但我当时完全没意识到。
It's got to be true, right? Like, that's clearly, to me as an adult-- if you're like hey, there's this little kid who'll come over and do magic for your party, I'm like, done.
这肯定是真的，对吧？作为一个成年人，如果有人跟我说，嘿，有个小孩可以来你的聚会上表演魔术，我肯定会说：成交。
Fact is, when I usually think about my years doing magic shows, the biggest feeling I have about it is I feel embarrassment. There's like a cloud of embarrassment that keeps me from staring at it too closely. Like, I know I was doing these store-bought tricks and beginners-level sleight of hand in a tuxedo and bow tie and a cape with a bright red lining. And what I remember of the act, some of it is pretty corny.
事实上，每当我回想起当年表演魔术的那些年，我最大的感觉就是尴尬。有一团尴尬的迷雾笼罩着那段记忆，让我不敢细看。我知道我当时穿着燕尾服、打着领结、披着红色内衬的斗篷，在表演那些商店买来的初级手法。我现在记得的部分表演，其实挺俗气的。
But at the same time, I can say for sure, like, audiences were engaged. They were engaged from beginning to end. Like, people were not restless. And I know I got laughs. And I thought I was good. Like, it seemed like I was good. So was I? [LAUGHS] After talking to David, I realized I do not have a clear picture of this at all. And you know, there are things about our past that we'll never fully get into proper perspective. But this? This is a completely answerable question.
但同时，我可以肯定地说，观众当时确实被吸引住了。他们从头到尾都很专注，一点也不觉得无聊。我知道我逗笑了他们，我也以为自己演得很好。那我到底水平怎么样呢？[笑声] 和大卫聊完后，我意识到我对那段经历根本没有清晰的认识。你知道，过去有些事情我们永远无法从正确的角度去看待。但这件呢？这完全是一个可以得到答案的问题。
So I called Judy Meltzer, who was a good friend of my mom's when my mom was alive, who lived around the corner from us. And who booked me not once but twice for her daughter Amy's birthdays.
所以我给朱迪·梅尔策打了电话。她在我们家附近住，是我妈还在世时的好友，她不仅请我表演过一次，还为她女儿艾米的两次生日订了我的演出。
First of all, I mean, you did it for quite a time. Because one time-- I mean, I wanted to get your magic tricks for your bar mitzvah. Which you almost didn't have, as I recall.
首先，你确实表演了很长一段时间。因为有一次——我想为你准备的受戒礼（Bar Mitzvah）买些魔术道具。我记得你当时差点没办成那个仪式。
That's right.
没错。
Anyway, and I went to the magic store-- your mother gave me the name of it-- downtown, the one you frequented. And you were very good at it.
总之，我去了那家魔术店——你妈给了我地址——就在市中心，你常去的那家。你当时变得很棒。
Well, this is the thing I was trying to get a fix on, is was I bad?
这就是我一直想确认的，我当时演得很烂吗？
No, are you kidding me? You think I would have-- of course not! You were great. You did a terrific job. You liked it a lot. You think you're doing something different now?
不，你在开玩笑吗？你以为我会……当然不是！你很棒。你做得很出色。你当时非常喜欢它。你觉得你现在做的事和那时有什么不同吗？
[LAUGHS] Yes, I am doing something different now.
[笑声] 是的，我现在做的事确实不同了。
No, you're not. No, you're not. Oh, no. I'm sorry. I don't buy that. OK. You think what you want, I'll think what I want.
不，你并没有。不，你不是。噢，不，对不起。我不买账。好吧，你想怎么认为就怎么认为吧。
Wait, wait, wait. You're saying when you hear me on the radio, it reminds you of my magic act?
等等，等等。你是说当你在广播里听到我声音时，会让想起我的魔术表演？
It reminds me of who you have always been, as far as I'm concerned. You were good. And not only that, you had a spiel, of course, that went with it. Wasn't that you just kind of did a trick and stuck it out there.
在我看来，那提醒了我你一直以来是什么样的人。你当时演得很好。不仅如此，你当然还有一套与之配合的台词，不是说你变个魔术就把道具扔在那儿就行了。
Yeah.
是的。
Like that's it, and you-- no. You had a nice flowing reper-- what do you call it?
就像那样，你……不。你有一套流畅的……那叫什么来着？
A patter.
口条（patter）。
Patter? OK, thank you. Yeah. You did that. But I know you were very professional, with the outfit and everything.
口条？好的，谢谢。对，你当时就是这么做的。而且我知道你非常专业，穿着那套衣服什么的。
Yeah. I wore a cape.
是的，我还披着斗篷。
Yes! By the way, you didn't just wear the cape. You used it.
没错！顺便说一句，你可不仅仅是披着斗篷，你是真的“使用”了它。
[LAUGHS] What do you mean? What did I do with the cape? What are you talking about?
[笑声] 什么意思？我怎么使用斗篷了？你在说什么？
You know, like you would flip the side back. And it was a very professional way of wearing the cape.
你知道的，比如你会把一边翻过来。那是非常专业的斗篷穿戴方式。
Yeah, I loved that cape.
是的，我很喜欢那件斗篷。
[LAUGHS] Yes.
[笑声] 是的。
OK. Reassuring. But after David and I realized our common conjuring careers as Magical Mystifier and Master Magician, we were talking, and we realized that so much of our pleasure in magic was just knowing how the tricks were done. The equipment itself was kind of mesmerizing, with its false chambers and flaps and secrets that the audience didn't know. Every trick had a principle behind it. And it was cool to think about the principles.
好的，这让我很欣慰。但当大卫和我意识到我们曾作为“魔幻神秘师”和“魔术大师”拥有共同的职业生涯后，我们发现，我们对魔术的大部分乐趣其实仅仅来自于了解魔术是如何运作的。道具本身就有一种催眠般的魅力，那些虚假的隔层、翻板，以及观众不知道的秘密。每一个魔术背后都有一个原理，而思考这些原理是非常酷的事情。
The magician Ricky Jay once said this thing in an interview. He said that there are many effects in magic where what's going on behind the scenes is actually much more interesting than what the audience sees. And as a magician, you sort of want to say, if only you could know what's really happening here.
魔术师瑞奇·杰伊（Ricky Jay）曾经在一次采访中说，魔术中有许多表演，其后台正在发生的事情实际上比观众看到的要有趣得多。作为魔术师，你有时真想说：要是你们能知道这里面到底发生了什么就好了。
In putting today's show together, David and I dove into a bunch of stories with actual master magicians. And I have to say, the most exciting moments in all those stories are about that. About how intricate and psychological and ingenious what they do is. And even as we've been writing and editing the stories over and over, I've gotten that feeling of excitement about it that I used to get handling the props or practicing the cups and balls.
在策划今天的节目时，大卫和我深入探讨了许多真正魔术大师的故事。我必须说，所有这些故事中最令人兴奋的时刻就在于此：他们所做的事情是多么复杂、充满心理学色彩且独具匠心。甚至在我们一遍又一遍撰写和剪辑这些故事时，我也找回了那种曾经在摆弄道具或练习纸牌戏法时感受到的兴奋感。
And that's today's show. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这就是今天的节目。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one-- the oldest trick in the book. It can take years to come up with a magic trick. Several magicians told me this. Which made me wonder, what are they doing all that time? What takes years to make something that's just a couple of minutes long? And this is the part of magic I really knew nothing about from my time as a kid magician. I never invented a trick. Didn't even occur to me.
第一幕：老掉牙的把戏。想出一个魔术可能需要数年时间，好几位魔术师都跟我这么说过。这让我感到好奇，他们到底在那儿琢磨什么？是什么花了几年时间去创造一个只有几分钟长的东西？这是我小时候做魔术师时完全不知道的部分。我从来没有发明过魔术，甚至想都没想过。
So I wanted to see it. You know how on MTV Cribs, when they would do the house tours and get to the bedrooms, guys would always say, this is where the magic happens. And, OK, very different context. But the act of inventing a magic trick, that's actually where the magic happens. And I wanted to finally witness the dark beating heart of where magic comes from. I wanted a magician to explain step by step what takes years.
所以我很想亲眼看看。你知道MTV的《名人家居》（Cribs）节目里，当他们带大家参观卧室时，男主人总会说：这就是“发生魔术”的地方。嗯，虽然语境完全不同，但发明一个魔术的过程，确实就是“发生魔术”的地方。我终于想见证魔术诞生的那颗跳动的心脏。我想让一位魔术师一步步解释是什么花了他几年的时间。
And the one magician who seemed not just interested, but actually kind of eager to come forward and do that was Teller of Penn and Teller. Teller is the smaller one, the one who never speaks in the act. But of course, in real life, he talks. And he liked the idea of explaining how a trick is made. He once said in a lecture, because--
而唯一一位不仅感兴趣，甚至迫切想要站出来分享的魔术师，就是“潘与泰勒”（Penn and Teller）中的泰勒。泰勒是身材较小的那位，表演中从不说话。当然，现实生活中他会说话。他喜欢解释魔术制作过程的想法。他曾在一场讲座中说，因为……
If you understand a good magic trick-- and I mean really understand it, right down to the mechanics at the core of its psychology-- the magic trick gets better, not worse.
如果你能看懂一个好的魔术——我是说真正看懂，从心理学核心到机械装置——那个魔术只会变得更好，而不是更差。
The trick he agreed to explain here on the radio is one that he loves to perform. He performs a lot. And he started working on it years ago, looking to invent something new for Penn and Teller's live stage show.
他同意在电台解释的这个魔术，是他非常热衷表演的。他经常表演这个。他多年前就开始研究它，试图为“潘与泰勒”的现场舞台秀发明一些新东西。
There was this old effect that he was intrigued by. It seemed like there might be something in it that he could adapt for himself. It's not unusual for a magician like Teller to take some secret from a very old trick, and repurpose it into something original. This particular one came from a magic book written in the 1920s and '30s by a guy in Nebraska named David P Abbott, an amateur magician who made his living as a loanshark. He was famous among magicians back then. He'd invent these incredible effects and perform them, but only in his living room. He thought that was the best place for magic.
有一个他很感兴趣的老式魔术。他觉得里面可能有些东西可以为自己所用。像泰勒这样的魔术师从旧魔术中汲取秘密，并将其改造成原创作品是很常见的。这个魔术来自20世纪20和30年代的一本魔术书，作者是内布拉斯加州一个叫大卫·P·阿博特（David P Abbott）的人，他是个业余魔术师，职业是高利贷者。他在当时的魔术圈很有名。他发明了一些不可思议的魔术并在家里表演，他认为那是表演魔术的最佳场所。
Houdini, Thurston, Keller-- all the big names of magic would come to this guy's little house in Omaha, Nebraska to see these great shows. And towards the end of his life, when people would come to his house, he would show you the book that he had that was all of his magic explained in detail. He died. The book wasn't published. His wife said she would publish it. She died two years later. The house was sold. The book had vanished.
胡迪尼、瑟斯顿、凯勒——魔术界的所有大人物都会去内布拉斯加州奥马哈市他那栋小房子里看表演。在他生命的最后阶段，当人们去他家时，他会给他们看一本详细解释了他所有魔术的手稿。他去世了，书没出版。他妻子说她会出版，但两年后她也去世了。房子被卖了，书也不知去向。
It was a legend in a certain corner of the magic world, this lost book with these incredible secrets. One publisher went on a decades long quest to locate the book. Found pieces of it, and then finally, a full manuscript in four legal-size loose-leaf binders, 40 years later in 1974, and put it into print for the first time.
那本书在魔术界某个圈子里成了一个传奇，记载着不可思议的秘密。一位出版商花了数十年寻找这本书。40年后的1974年，他终于找到了分落在四个法律尺寸活页夹里的完整手稿，并将其首次印刷出版。
And the trick that attracted Teller was this golden ball, six inches across like a small cannonball, that Abbott could float around his living room. That was supposed to be one of the most beautiful routines in magic. That's exactly Teller's taste. Teller loves doing silent, beautiful tricks alone on stage. And solo bits like this are in every Penn and Teller stage show. His most famous trick is a pantomime, with a rose, its shadow, and a carving knife.
吸引泰勒的那个魔术是一个金色的球，直径六英寸，像个小炮弹，阿博特能让它在客厅里悬浮。那被认为是魔术中最优美的表演之一。这正好符合泰勒的品味。泰勒喜欢在舞台上独自表演无声而优美的魔术。像这样的个人秀存在于每一场“潘与泰勒”的舞台演出中。他最著名的魔术是哑剧，关于一朵玫瑰、它的影子和一把雕刻刀。
I like stripping things down to the absolute simplicity. And it seems like a ball and a hoop and a person is about as simple as you can get.
我喜欢把事情剥离到最极致的简单。而球、环和人似乎就是能做到的最简单组合了。
So, he got to work.
于是，他开始动手了。
And I started by taking the original David P Abbott book, this long lost book, and I set this book on a music stand in my library at home. And I learned this.
我首先把大卫·P·阿博特的原著——那本失传已久的书——放在家里的谱架上，然后开始学习。
Let me just pause on this page. So this is a page which has seven photographs. And is that Abbott?
让我在这页停一下。这一页有七张照片。那是阿博特吗？
That's David P Abbott, yes. He looks a bit like a white-haired fireplug.
是的，那就是大卫·P·阿博特。他看起来有点像个白发苍苍的消防栓。
And he's in a black suit. And he's moving a hoop over a ball. And there's little arrows indicating which way you turn it, this way and that.
他穿着黑色西装，正在让一个环绕过一个球。旁边有小箭头指示转动方向，这边一下，那边一下。
Yes. The level of detail that he provided was astounding. So I mean, I feel like he is speaking directly to me. He tells you how to make the papier-mache that you make the ball out of! You know, strips of newspaper, x wide. And let me let me show you some of the beautiful, beautiful floating moves that he created.
是的。他提供的细节程度令人惊叹。我觉得他简直是在直接跟我对话。他告诉你制作那个球的纸糊该怎么做！你知道的，用多宽的报纸条。让我给你们展示一下他创造的一些美丽、美丽的悬浮动作。
OK, we're standing up and walking across the stage.
好的，我们站起来，走过舞台。
Maybe I should have mentioned this earlier-- Teller and my coworker David Kestenbaum and I are doing this interview on the stage where Penn and Teller do their magic show five nights a week in Las Vegas, in a big theater at the Rio Hotel.
也许我该早点提到的——泰勒、我的同事大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆和我，正在拉斯维加斯里约大酒店的剧院舞台上进行这次采访，也就是“潘与泰勒”每周表演五晚魔术的地方。
And we're going to have to go quite a distance to get this to work.
为了完成这个动作，我们得走一段距离。
Teller picks up the ball and the thread. He asked us not to say anything here on the radio about the details of where the thread goes or how exactly it interacts with the ball. But there's still a lot I can say. So picture a guy and a hoop and a ball and a very long thread on a stage.
泰勒拿起了球和线。他要求我们不要在电台里提及线的位置，或者它到底是如何与球交互的细节。但除此之外，我还是有很多可以说的。所以，想象一下舞台上有一个人、一个环、一个球和一根很长的线。
The early days of this, I'm learning moves to make the ball float.
早期的练习阶段，我在学习让球悬浮的动作。
And now I'll say, the ball is floating up the string toward you, and then from your left hand to your right hand.
现在我说，球正在沿着线向你飘过来，然后从左手飘向右手。
You're actually catching the sound of it, which is not normally audible to an audience member.
你实际上捕捉到了它的声音，这在观众席上通常是听不见的。
Actually, can I just record-- can you just do it--
其实，我可以录下来吗？你能再做一次吗？
[STRING GLIDE SOUND]
[线滑动的声音]
Teller gestures at the ball like he's summoning it with his hand. And it glides along the thread to him. That's the sound you're hearing. And what's mind-bending is that David and I can actually see that he's tilting the thread downwards, and that's why it slides towards him. Like we can see the ball is on a thread. We can see how it's done. We hear it sliding along.
泰勒对着球做出手势，仿佛在用手召唤它。它沿着线滑向他，这就是你们听到的声音。令人难以置信的是，大卫和我实际上能看见他正在将线向下倾斜，这就是球滑向他的原因。我们可以看到球在一条线上，也能看到它是如何完成的。我们听到了它在滑动。
God, that's pretty.
天哪，太美了。
And at the same time, it totally looks like he's this sorcerer who enchanted this inanimate object into obeying him.
与此同时，这看起来完全就像他是位巫师，让这个无生命的物体听命于他。
Dude, that is so beautiful actually when you see the thread.
伙计，当你真的看到线的时候，这真的很美。
Yes, it is. I mean, here's one of David P Abbott's moves that he invented. The ball is floating from hand to hand without really any movement on the part of either of the hands, just by an intricate way that the thread is interlaced in the fingers.
是的，确实。看，这是大卫·P·阿博特发明的一个动作。球在两手之间飘来飘去，两只手几乎没有任何动作，仅仅通过线在手指间缠绕的复杂方式完成。
He then takes the hoop and spins it around the ball in various ways, which makes it look like there can't possibly be a thread there. But of course, we can see the thread.
然后他拿着环，以各种方式围绕着球转动，这看起来绝不可能有线。但当然，我们能看见那根线。
Can I say that's crazy? That's so convincing. Your brain really cannot sort that out.
我可以评价说这太疯狂了吗？太令人信服了。你的大脑真的无法拆解它。
Your brain cannot sort this out. It's visual double-talk. It's amazing. And I'm sitting here and I'm doing it, and it's still fooling my brain.
你的大脑确实无法拆解它。这是视觉上的连篇鬼话，太惊人了。我就坐在这里，看着他演示，它依然在欺骗我的大脑。
Which I totally remember from being a kid magician, and practicing the thumb palm and the French drop and all the other sleight of hand in front of a mirror. If you do it right, it fools you. It feels amazing to you. And that's how you know the trick is working.
这完全唤起了我小时候做魔术师的记忆，当时我在镜子前练习大拇指隐藏法、法式抛物线和其他戏法。如果你做得对，连你自己都会被骗住。那种感觉太棒了，那就是你知道魔术成功了的方式。
So this was Teller's first step toward inventing his own version of the trick. He spent months mastering David P Abbott's moves from 100 years ago. And started to figure out what else he could make the ball do on his own. He would practice everyday. He took the ball and thread on vacation with him, and videotaped himself to see how the moves looked.
这就是泰勒发明自己版本魔术的第一步。他花了几个月时间掌握100年前大卫·P·阿博特的动作，并开始琢磨还能让球独自做出什么效果。他每天都练习。他去度假时也带着球和线，还给自己录像，看这些动作看起来效果如何。
Oh, no-- well, I'll show you this one. Here I am in a cabin in Utah in my pajamas. [LAUGHS] I was just obsessed with it.
噢，不——好吧，给你们看这个。这是我在犹他州的一间小屋里，穿着睡衣的样子。[笑声] 我当时简直对它着了迷。
He took a trip to Toronto where a magician friend taught him the version of the floating ball routine that he did. And then when Teller was there, he tried this thing, just kind of messing around. He put the ball on a bench, and lifted one end of the bench. And then made the ball roll up the bench.
他去了一趟多伦多，一位魔术师朋友教了他一套悬浮球表演的套路。泰勒在那里时尝试了一些东西，纯粹是闹着玩。他把球放在长凳上，抬起长凳一头，让球滚动起来。
And then later, he had this thought-- that the floating ball was actually more interesting to watch when it's not floating. When it's just this ball that's somehow alive and rolling around. It's weirder and it's more mysterious. It's less clear what's propelling it.
后来，他有了一个想法——其实悬浮球在“不悬浮”的时候反而更有趣。当它只是一个看起来活灵活现、滚来滚去的球时，它显得更怪诞、更神秘。你更搞不清楚是什么在推动它。
It began to cross my mind that no one had ever done a floating ball that didn't float. And I was jubilant. I thought, oh boy, I finally got an idea! I finally got an original idea to go with this method.
我开始产生了一个念头：从来没有人做过一个“不悬浮的悬浮球”。我简直欣喜若狂。我想，天哪，我终于有个好主意了！我终于为这个手法找到了一个原创的概念。
The next step was to put something together into a routine-- like an actual trick as it might be performed. This involved a tremendous amount of invention, making up all kinds of new moves on his own for the floating ball that does not float.
下一步是把它串成套路——一个真正可以表演的魔术。这涉及大量的发明工作，为这个“不悬浮的悬浮球”编排了各种全新的动作。
Here's a move where I kick it across the stage and it lands softly.
这是我踢它横穿舞台，然后它轻柔落下的动作。
Let me just describe what you're doing. So you're kicking the ball and it's going maybe 12 feet out there.
让我描述一下你正在做的。你踢了那个球，它飞出了大约12英尺。
And then suddenly coming to a stop.
然后突然停住了。
And just sitting on the floor.
就停在地板上。
What you would think in real life, if you kick a ball, the ball doesn't stop until it runs out of momentum. So this is suddenly that ball stops, stops dead. Unbelievably difficult. It's me using leverage and slack and all sorts of things like that.
在现实生活中，如果你踢一个球，它不会在动量耗尽前停下来。所以这个球突然就停了，死死地停住。这难得难以置信。是我利用了杠杆、线的松弛度以及各种类似的技巧。
He spent months inventing these moves at night, alone in the theater, after they finished their shows. And all this was preparation to show his partner, Penn, who at this point hadn't seen anything. It was a lot of preparation. All sorts of things. Like he'd been practicing with a silver ball, like David P Abbott's mysterious floating gold orb. But now he replaced it with a kid's ball that bounced, the size of a kickball. Because magic is more magical if you do it with real stuff that people know.
他在剧场关门后，独自一人花了好几个月在晚上研究这些动作。所有的准备都是为了展示给他的搭档潘看，当时潘还没看过任何东西。准备工作非常多，比如他一直在练习用银球，就像大卫·P·阿博特那神秘的金球一样。但现在他换成了一个会弹跳的小孩玩的球，大小像个踢球。因为魔术如果用人们熟悉的真实物品来表演，会显得更魔幻。
And he built a set. It was chain-link fence, because he thought, where do you see a kid's ball? At a playground. But, he says, when he put the chain-link fence up on stage, it suddenly felt like the set of Godspell. And he ditched it.
他还搭建了一个背景，用的是铁丝网，因为他想，小孩的球通常在哪里见到？在操场上。但是他说，当他把铁丝网立在舞台上时，突然感觉像是在拍音乐剧《上帝之子》（Godspell）。于是他放弃了这个点子。
David and I asked Teller, why didn't you just show Penn something rough? Just something with the moves you'd been inventing. And he said, no. no, no. That's the thing about magic.
大卫和我问泰勒，为什么不直接给潘看个半成品？展示一下你一直在发明的那些动作。他说，不，不，不。魔术就是这样。
You can't look at a half-finished piece of magic and know whether it's good or not. It has to be perfect before you can evaluate whether it's good. I mean, magic is a fantastically meticulous form. You forgive other forms. A musician misses a note, moves on, fine. He'll come to the conclusion of the piece. Magic is an on/off switch. Either it looks like a miracle or it's stupid.
你无法通过看一个未完成的魔术来判断它好不好。它必须完美无瑕，你才能评价它的优劣。魔术是一门极其严谨的艺术形式。其他艺术形式你会包容瑕疵。音乐家漏掉一个音符，继续演下去也没事。魔术则是一个“开/关”开关。它要么看起来像个奇迹，要么就是蠢透了。
So I spent up-- I would guess it was probably 11 months or so, putting together a routine of moves that I invented with the non-floating floating ball. And I showed it to Penn.
所以我花了……我猜大概11个月左右，排练了这套我发明的“不悬浮悬浮球”动作，然后表演给潘看。
Describe the act that he saw. Like what was it?
描述一下他看到的表演，是什么样的？
I believe that what he saw was very, very artsy. It was very lonely. It was very sweetly melancholy. I was trying to recreate that sense of solitude in a theater late at night.
我相信他看到的是非常、非常艺术化的。非常孤独，带有一点甜美的忧郁。我试图在深夜的剧院里重现那种孤独感。
And he sat way back in the theater, way towards the back, so that he could get a wide stage view of it. I finished it. And he quietly got up and left the theater. And I thought, hmm, that's probably not a good sign. So I went back to his dressing room, and we talked for a while.
他坐在剧院的最后面，这样可以看清整个舞台。我演完了，他静静地起身离开。我心想，这恐怕不是什么好兆头。我回到他的化妆室，我们聊了一会儿。
I remember being in the dressing room and being really, really, really wicked uncomfortable.
我记得当时在化妆室里，感觉真的非常、非常、非常不自在。
This, of course, is Teller's stage partner, Penn Jillette.
这就是泰勒的搭档，潘·吉列特（Penn Jillette）。
There was nothing about it that grabbed me. I thought it was technically good as a juggling bit, I thought it was OK.
它没有任何打动我的地方。我觉得作为杂耍片段，它在技术上还行，感觉就那样。
Juggling, he means the mechanics of moving the ball around.
他说的杂耍，指的是移动球的技巧。
It was the first time we really had something that outside of the overlap.
这是我们第一次真正有了某种超出我们重合部分的东西。
To get into the Penn and Teller Show, it has to be an idea that appeals to both Penn and me. And he said-- and to his credit, he said that he thought it was way too Cirque Du Soleil. It was way too sort of artsy, pretentious.
要进入“潘与泰勒”的节目，这个想法必须同时吸引我和潘。正如他所说的，他认为这太像“太阳马戏团”了。太艺术化、太做作了。
I remember Teller getting a little bit mad at me. Because I said, what's the idea behind this? And he was very offended. He was like, well, the idea is the trick. You know?
我记得泰勒当时有点生我的气。因为我问，这背后的创意是什么？他被冒犯了，他说：创意就是这个魔术本身，你懂吗？
And I think it hadn't clicked with him because it lacked an essential dramatic idea. Of course, to me, I was all wrapped up in the idea that it was a floating ball that wasn't floating, which isn't a very good idea. I mean, that's not an idea that communicates to an audience.
我觉得他当时没想通，是因为它缺乏一个核心的戏剧创意。当然，我当时沉浸在“这是一个不悬浮的悬浮球”这个点子上，这其实并不是个好创意。这没法传达给观众。
The next day at Starbucks, they talked about what idea might work with the trick. Penn suggested presenting it as a kind of history piece. An old classic with period music. That kind of thing they would do in a magic history conference. Teller got excited about that. Emailed him later, adding to the idea. Like they'd tell the audience he was using a method from a hundred years ago, without electronic technology and no help from offstage.
第二天在星巴克，他们讨论了什么创意能配合这个魔术。潘建议把它呈现为一个“历史片段”。一种带有时代音乐的老经典。那种他们会在魔术历史会议上表演的东西。泰勒对这个想法很兴奋，后来发邮件补充说：他们可以告诉观众这是在用100年前的方法，没有电子技术，没有幕后协助。
Imagining that version of the trick, Penn wrote him back, quote, "From reading this, I've lost a little faith in the idea. I guess we can try this. But it doesn't seem to bring another level in. Maybe we should just do it the way you wanted, and not look for more here. I'm sure people will like it fine. I don't know. This seems to make a lot of what I didn't like maybe worse. I don't know. I don't have to like every bit in the show, that's for sure,"
潘回信想象了那个版本的魔术，写道：“读完这些，我对这个想法失去了一点信心。我想我们可以试试。但这似乎并没有带来什么新层级。也许我们应该按你想要的做，不要再试图挖掘更多了。我相信观众会喜欢的。我不知道。这反而让很多我不喜欢的地方变得更糟了。我不知道。我可以确定的一点是，我不必喜欢节目里的每一个片段。”
Teller didn't like that. Seemed wrong for Penn to settle. He got back to work to solve the problem. And here's where making this trick turn from just the mechanics of moving a ball around on a thread to actually thinking through what tells a story, what's engaging, what's fun to watch, what's satisfying. And Teller realized one of the things that was missing from the trick. He says any magic trick is better if there's a reason the magic happens. So for instance--
泰勒不喜欢那样。潘妥协了，这让他感觉不对劲。他回去继续解决这个问题。这里就是魔术从单纯的动作机械化，转变为思考如何讲故事、如何更有趣、更吸引人、更满足观众的过程。泰勒意识到这个魔术缺少了一样东西。他说任何魔术如果有了“发生的理由”会变得更好。举例来说：
If you put, let's say, a coin into your hand, close your hand, snap your fingers, open it, and the coin is gone, there's not much of an impact to that. And the reason for that is that the action seems arbitrary. That there doesn't seem to be a cause that makes that event happen.
如果你把硬币放进手里，合上，打个响指，张开手，硬币没了，这没多大冲击力。原因是那个动作显得很随意，没有一个原因导致了事件发生。
Oh, like why would a coin disappear.
就像，硬币为什么会消失？
Yes. If you put the same coin in your hand, close your hand, and even do just this-- even just, say, take out a match. Light the match, pass it around your hand, and act with a sudden jolt as though something has happened inside your head where the coin melted away, and you've been burnt. And you open your hand and there's no coin now. That level of acting, that level of causality that suggests that somehow the fire of a match could make a coin melt away, suddenly adds a dimension to it that I think is pretty crucial.
是的。如果你把同样的硬币放进手里，合上，甚至只需做这个——比如拿出火柴，点燃火柴，绕着你的手转一圈，然后突然像有什么事发生在脑海里，硬币融化了，你自己被烫到了一样。你张开手，硬币不见了。那种表演的力度，那种暗示火柴火焰可能让硬币融化的逻辑，瞬间增加了一个维度，我觉得这非常关键。
Also, it gives it a story.
而且它赋予了它一个故事。
It gives it a little bit of a story. It gives it emotion. And I realized that I was doing all of this stuff with nothing causing it. There was no cause. Why is the ball moving around? The ball is just moving around. It was just arbitrary movement.
赋予了它一点故事性，赋予了情感。我意识到我之前做的那些动作没有任何缘由。球为什么要动？球只是在动。那纯粹是随意的移动。
One of Teller's collaborators, a veteran magician named Johnny Thompson, gave him a suggestion that changed everything, though. He said you've got to treat the book like a trained dog. That would give a reason for its movement. A logic, a cause. So Teller tried it.
泰勒的合作者之一，资深魔术师强尼·汤普森（Johnny Thompson）给了一个改变一切的建议。他说：你得把这个球当成训练有素的狗。这会给它的移动提供理由、逻辑和起因。泰勒试了试。
I thought, well, you know, what does typically a trained dog do? It jumps through a hoop. So a trained dog is not always going to do what you want it to do. So I'd hold up the hoop, and the dog wouldn't respond. I'd call the dog, and instead of jumping through the hoop, it would come over and land on the rim of the hoop. I sit down and ignore it. What does a dog do when you ignore it? Well, it very often comes to you.
我想，通常受过训练的狗会做什么？它会跳过环。所以训练好的狗不一定会完全听你指挥。我会举起环，狗没反应。我叫狗，它没跳环，反而走到环边上停住。我坐下来无视它。当无视狗的时候它会做什么？通常它会向你走过来。
And here's what's happening. What's happening is, I'm realizing that the plot of this is the dog trainer is getting the dog to jump through a hoop. That becomes the plot. That becomes a little bit of a story.
发生的情况是：我意识到这个表演的剧情就是“驯狗师想让狗跳环”。这成了剧情，这就有了故事。
Now he had a plot and a story. Teller did something else at this stage that's so essential and basic to the kind of drama that particularly happens in a magic show.
现在他有了情节和故事。泰勒在这个阶段还做了另一件事，这对于魔术秀中的戏剧性来说非常基础且关键。
One of the things that you do as a magician is you try to put yourself in the position of the audience at every moment. And you say, what would I be thinking at this moment? And you try to manipulate that. And one of the ways you do that is by giving the audience a little chance to figure something out, and then take it away from them.
魔术师要做的就是尝试在每一刻都置身于观众的角度。你会问，在这个时刻我在想什么？然后尝试去操纵这种想法。其中一种方式就是给观众一点机会让他们想出答案，然后又夺走它。
And so he does that with this routine. Re-imagines it. The ball starts on the bench, always in contact with the bench. So the audience will think the ball is controlled by the bench. And then he lifts the ball off the bench. It sticks to his finger and floats in the air. So they might conclude that it's his finger that controls the ball. And then it drops to the floor, away from his finger.
所以他用这个套路做了尝试，重新构思了它。球从长凳上开始，始终保持接触，这样观众会认为球是被长凳控制的。然后他把球从长凳上拿开，它贴在手指上悬浮在空中。观众会认为是他手指控制了球。然后球掉到地上，离开了手指。
So each time you think of something, I give you the chance to think of that, and then I take it away from you, one thing after the other.
所以每当你想到一个解释，我就给你机会去确认它，然后接着就把它夺走，一个接一个。
It takes a lot of work. He finishes the new routine, shows it to his partner Penn, who hates it. Truly, truly hates it.
这花了很多功夫。他完成了新的套路，给潘展示。潘讨厌它，真心实意地讨厌它。
Yes, he makes it further away from what my taste would be. [LAUGHS] At least when it was an abstract moving thing, it's closer to my taste. Once it becomes something like a dog, it's moved very far out of my taste.
是的，它让我感觉离我的审美更远了。[笑声] 至少当它只是一个抽象移动物体时，还离我的审美近一点。一旦它变成了像狗之类的东西，就完全偏离我的喜好了。
Because you hate an animated object.
因为你讨厌拟人化物体。
I do! I do! I hate anthropomorphism. I don't like relationships with animals or inanimate objects at all.
确实！我讨厌！我讨厌拟人化。我不喜欢和动物或无生命物体建立任何关系。
Which is basically what this is.
而这基本上就是它在做的事。
Yeah. But see, the thing is, where is my argument?
是啊。但问题是，我的论点在哪儿呢？
Where is his argument? Like, what is he supposed to say? This is a delicate conversation, right? Here are these two men who respect each other, but don't socialize or hang out together. Who have been arguing, they say, constantly and fiercely, but productively for over 40 years. And Penn knows how much work Teller has put into this trick. And how much he would enjoy performing it every night.
他的论点在哪儿？比如，他该说什么？这对话很微妙，对吧？这里有两个互相尊重但并不社交、不混在一起的男人。他们说，40多年来他们一直在激烈地争论，但这种争论也是富有成效的。潘知道泰勒在那个魔术上付出了多少心血，也知道他每晚表演它会有多开心。
He's not saying this outright, but it's implicit-- this is beautiful. This is mystifying. This is entertaining. People will love it. It's really important to me. All those five things are true. So it's very, very uncomfortable.
他没直说，但意思很明确：这很美，这很神奇，这很有趣，人们会喜欢的，这对我也很重要。这五点都成立。所以这非常、非常让人不自在。
Uncomfortable because Penn agrees. It's a great trick. Totally works. He just doesn't like it. It doesn't feel like their show to him, this red ball that's also a disobedient puppy. That's like the kind of idea you might see in a cartoon. And they try to build the show around the principle that there should be nothing in the show that feels even vaguely familiar to the audience. Nothing you can imagine seeing in anybody else's work.
不自在是因为潘也同意这是一个伟大的魔术，完全可行。他只是不喜欢它。对他来说，这个既是红球又是顽皮小狗的表演，感觉不像他们的节目。这就像你在卡通片里看到的创意。他们试图围绕一个原则建立节目：节目中不能有任何让观众感到哪怕有一点熟悉的东西。没有什么你能想象在别人作品里看到的东西。
So Penn doesn't say yes. But he doesn't say no either. He says to Teller, to be in the show, it still needs one more idea to really make it ours. And out of respect for each other, they try to come up with that idea.
所以潘没有答应。但他也没拒绝。他告诉泰勒：要加入节目，它还需要一个想法，才能真正让它成为我们的。出于相互尊重，他们试图想出那个想法。
And I don't know which one of us brought it up. I think I'm the one who said, what if we actually said-- I said, you know, when Mike Close and Johnny Thompson came and watched me do this trick--
我不知道是谁提出来的。我想是我说的。你知道吗，当迈克·克洛斯（Mike Close）和强尼·汤普森来看我做这个魔术时——
These are two other magicians they admire.
这是他们敬佩的另外两位魔术师。
--they knew there was a thread there. And because they knew there was a thread there, they were more baffled than an audience that could imagine that this was being done with a little gyroscope inside the ball. So I said, what if we say right out at the top, here's a trick that's done with a piece of thread and a special backdrop. And Penn said, I think all you need is, now here's a trick that's done with a piece of thread.
——他们知道那儿有一根线。正因为知道有线，他们比那些会猜测球里装了陀螺仪的普通观众更感到困惑。所以我说：如果我们一开始就直接说“这是一个用线和特殊背景完成的魔术”会怎样？潘说：我觉得你只需要说“这是一个用线完成的魔术”。
That gives them so much. It brings them over onto our side. And suddenly, this now had an idea. And the idea was bigger than the little plot with the little ball. It was bigger than all the little magic tricks. It was that you can state the actual method of a magic trick clearly at the beginning of it, and it can still fool the hell out of people. That by knowing this extra piece of information, the trick becomes better.
这给了他们很多。它把观众带到了我们这一边。突然，这魔术有了个“点子”。这个想法比那个小狗戏法更大，比所有小魔术都大。那就是：你可以清晰地陈述魔术的真相，但它依然能把人耍得团团转。通过提前知道这个额外信息，魔术反而变得更好了。
In other words, give the audience in the theater the same feeling that David and I had standing on stage, seeing the thread, and still feeling amazed. Not that the audience can see the thread, but they know it's there somewhere. Penn did lobby a little for sudden change in lighting that boom, would reveal the thread to the audience, fully visible. But in the end, this solution, just telling them about the thread, was enough for him.
换句话说，给观众泰勒和我站在舞台上看到那根线依然感到惊叹的那种感觉。不是说观众能看见线，但他们知道它肯定在某处。潘曾游说进行一次突然的灯光变化，直接将那根线完全暴露给观众。但最终，这个方案——告诉他们线存在——对他来说足够了。
And 18 months after Teller picked up David P Abbott's book to practice for the first time, he and Penn added the ball to their show. It's not the longest they've ever worked on a trick. Not even close. They told me about one that took them six years. And making anything good takes time.
在泰勒第一次拿起阿博特的书练习18个月后，他和潘把这个球加入到了演出中。这不是他们花费时间最长的魔术，差得远呢。他们告诉我有一个魔术花他们六年时间。创造任何好的东西都需要时间。
There's a quote that your partner of 40 years, Penn Jillette, said about you. It's kind of mean. There's no better partner than Teller. He's not the smartest or most creative person I've ever been around, but he's the hardest working. He will not give up. You can put him on a single task, and in the middle of it, hit him with a baseball bat square in the face, and he goes right back to the task.
你的搭档潘·吉列特曾这样评价你，有点刻薄：“没有比泰勒更好的搭档了。他不是我认识的人里最聪明或最有创造力的，但他工作最努力。他不会放弃。你可以让他做一个单一任务，在做的时候用棒球棍直接击中他的脸，他会立刻回到任务中去。”
[LAUGHS] Well, I'm sure he's talking directly about this bit. [LAUGHS] And that is true. It is true. I have a certain dog with a slipper quality about me. [LAUGHS] Especially-- I do trust my gut. This trick that we do in the show is not the trick that I thought we were going to do. But it is the trick that was calling out to me. You know?
[笑声] 嗯，我确定他是在说这个片段。[笑声] 这是真的。确实。我有一种像带着拖鞋的狗一样的特质。[笑声] 尤其是……我确实相信我的直觉。这个在节目里表演的魔术并不是我想象中我们会做的，但它是那个在召唤我的魔术。你懂吗？
Teller teared up as he said this. I told his partner, Penn.
泰勒说这些话时热泪盈眶。我告诉了他的搭档潘。
Yeah. He does. He does get choked up about it. There's stuff I get choked up about, too. That's not it.
是的。他确实会。他确实会对此感到哽咽。我也有让我哽咽的东西。这并不是什么稀奇事。
They are very different people, Penn and Teller. Even the way they tell this story, in Teller's telling, the story has a happy ending. They added the extra idea, compromise was reached. The partnership worked. When Penn tells the story, the compromise is a little deeper.
他们是截然不同的人，潘和泰勒。甚至在讲这个故事的方式上——在泰勒的叙述里，故事有个快乐结局，他们达成了妥协，伙伴关系奏效了。当潘讲这个故事时，妥协的意味则更深沉。
I think that Teller does a beautiful job and the audience loves it. And I kind of zone out. It doesn't feel like the whole bit just snaps into what it should be. You know it doesn't feel like--
我觉得泰勒做得非常漂亮，观众也很喜欢。但我当时就走神了。我感觉不到那个片段彻底“咔嗒”一声落入了它该在的位置。你知道吗，感觉不像……
You mean now? Even now?
你是说现在？即便现在也是？
Oh yeah, now. Yeah.
噢，是的，现在也是。是的。
Even now, you're not into that trick.
即便现在，你依然不喜欢那个魔术。
No. Maybe Teller may not know that. But, I mean, Teller may have noticed that every show order we come up with, at some point, I suggest we have a show without the red ball. He might notice that. I don't often note it. It is a pattern that shows up. But, can I say again, really good trick. He does a beautiful job. He worked really hard. And the audience loves it.
不喜欢。也许泰勒不知道这一点。但是，我是说，泰勒可能注意到了我们制定的每一次节目顺序里，我都会在某个点建议咱们去掉红球。他可能注意到了。我不常提起它。这确实是个反复出现的模式。但是，我得再说一次：真的很棒的魔术。他做得漂亮，他工作非常努力，观众也确实热爱它。
Teller told me, of course he knew that Penn still had his doubts. You don't work together so long, he said, without knowing something like that.
泰勒告诉我，他当然知道潘仍有疑虑。他说，你们不可能一起工作这么久而不知道这些事。
Interestingly, after five years of performing this trick, they changed the ending to add more of what Penn wanted, which is to underline the fact that it's done with the thread a little more. You can see this version of the trick online. There's a video from Penn & Teller's TV show, Fool Us. We have a link at our website.
有趣的是，在表演五年后，他们修改了结尾，加入更多潘想要的东西，即进一步强调它是用线完成的。你可以在网上看到这个版本。有一个来自他们电视节目《魔术大揭秘》（Fool Us）的视频。我们网站上有链接。
Here's what they added to finally finish the trick for good, over six years after Teller first started practicing with Abbott's book. At the end of the routine, Penn walks out onstage, grabs the thread from Teller, and then dangles the ball from the thread. Penn takes an oversized scissors, cuts the thread. The ball drops to the ground, and Penn kicks the ball across the stage. He looks mad. He's just acting, of course. But he lays into that ball with gusto.
这是他们最终定稿的版本，离泰勒第一次练习阿博特的书六年多了。在套路结束时，潘走到台前，从泰勒手中抓过线，晃动着球。潘拿出特大剪刀把线剪断，球掉在地上，潘把球踢向舞台另一侧。他看起来很生气。当然，他只是在演戏，但他确实充满激情地踢了那一脚。
Coming up, making a very, very big object-- an object too big to fit in a building-- making it disappear. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，制作一个非常、非常巨大的物体——大到无法放进建筑物的物体——让它消失。几分钟后在芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Magic Show." My coworker David Kestenbaum and I, both of us former kid magicians, return to magic as adults, and it all looks very different. Today's show was first broadcast a year ago.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“魔术秀”。我和我的同事大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，两位曾经的小魔术师，成年后重新审视魔术，感觉完全不同。今天的节目是一年前首播的。
We have arrived at act two of our program. Act two, The Lady Vanishes. So in putting together this show, David became obsessed with this one trick that he had seen back when he was a teenager. The Guinness Book of World Records lists it as the largest illusion ever staged. David wanted to know what it was like to be on the other side of that one. Like, what it was like to be the magician. Here he is.
现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，消失的女士。在策划这期节目时，大卫对他少年时期看到过的一个魔术产生了执念。《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》将其列为史上最大型的幻觉魔术。大卫想知道站在魔术背后是什么感觉。也就是，当魔术师是什么感觉。有请大卫。
This is a trick I loved when I was a kid. I'd kind of forgotten about it. And then one night, I was home recently watching the TV show, The Americans. The show is about this family living in the US in the 1980s. The parents are undercover Russian spies. Because it's set in the 1980s, these big historic moments pop up. President Reagan getting shot, Iran-Contra.
这是我小时候非常喜欢的一个魔术。我快忘了它了，直到最近一个晚上，我在家里看电视剧《美国谍梦》（The Americans）。这部剧讲的是20世纪80年代生活在美国的一个家庭，父母是潜伏的俄罗斯间谍。因为设定在80年代，那些重大的历史瞬间会穿插出现。里根总统遇刺、伊朗门事件。
But then this one episode, it opens with this--
但在某一集里，开头是这样的——
I remember this exact moment happening in my house. I was 13 years old, about the same age as those kids. And as a kid magician, I think I'd circled the time and channel in the TV Guide. That was our family system for reserving the television. When I've tried to relive this amazing moment in American history with other people, though, I get mostly blank stares. But I figured someone involved with The Americans must have been a nerd like me. Because there's like two minutes of the show where the family is just watching the trick on television.
我记得这事发生在我家。我当时13岁，跟那些孩子年纪差不多。作为一个小魔术师，我想我肯定在《电视指南》上圈出了时间和频道。那是我们家预留电视节目的系统。然而，当我试图和别人一起重温这个美国历史上的高光时刻时，大多数人只是茫然地看着我。但我猜《美国谍梦》的编剧里肯定有和我一样的书呆子。因为剧里有两分钟，那家人就在电视上看这个魔术。
So I reached out. And yeah, one of the producers of The Americans, Joel Fields, was just like me.
所以我联系了他们。果然，制片人之一乔尔·菲尔兹（Joel Fields）和我一样。
I was in my parent's wood-paneled den in Toronto, Canada, on their brown corduroy couch. It's extremely possible I brought some friends.
当时我在多伦多父母家铺着木板的客厅里，坐在棕色灯芯绒沙发上。我极有可能还带了朋友。
Just like me in one other way too.
他在另一件事上也跟我一样。
I was a magician.
我以前是个魔术师。
As a kid, the whole thing, hanging out at the local magic shop. His colleague Joe Weisberg was there, also-- the creator of The Americans. Joe kept ribbing us through the interview.
小时候整天混迹在当地魔术店。他的同事乔·魏斯伯格（Joe Weisberg）——《美国谍梦》的创始人也在场。采访过程中，乔一直拿我们开玩笑。
Where were you when you watched the David Copperfield special?
你看大卫·科波菲尔的特辑时你在哪儿？
Not watching the David Copperfield special.
没看大卫·科波菲尔的特辑。
Were even aware that it had happened?
你甚至知道它发生过吗？
I would have to say no.
我只能说不知道。
For those of you who were not following the national magic scene in the 1980s-- and I realize now there are many of you-- David Copperfield was one of two truly big name illusionists at the time. It felt like he was in a kind of battle with the other one, Doug Henning. Both had TV specials on separate networks. Copperfield was handsome, clean cut. Henning was the hippie, wearing tie dye with long hair and teeth that hadn't seen braces.
对于那些没在80年代关注魔术界的人——我现在意识到你们很多人都在此列——大卫·科波菲尔当时是两位名气最大的幻术大师之一。感觉他当时和另一位道格·亨宁（Doug Henning）处于一种竞争状态。两人在不同电视台都有特辑。科波菲尔英俊、帅气；亨宁则是嬉皮士，穿着扎染衣服，留长发，牙齿还没带过牙套。
I was squarely team Copperfield. My boss, Ira Glass, I learned while we were editing this story, 1,000% team Henning. Loved Henning's goofy sense of wonder. Which I hated. Copperfield, my man, seemed driven, intent on proving that he was the best in the world. Going bigger every time. In his previous TV special, he'd made an airplane disappear. Joe was somehow unaware of this too.
我坚定地站在科波菲尔阵营。在剪辑这期节目时，我得知我的老板艾拉·格拉斯是1000%的亨宁派。他爱死亨宁那种笨拙的惊奇感了，而我当时非常讨厌。科波菲尔是我的偶像，他看起来干劲十足，决心证明自己是世界第一，而且每次都要搞得更大。在之前的特辑里，他让一架飞机消失了。乔竟然对此一无所知。
Was the airplane on the ground or in the sky?
那飞机是在地面上还是在天上？
No, it was on the ground.
不，是在地面上。
Well, that's not-- you know.
嗯，那就不算……你知道的。
It was, actually. People stood around this airplane in a ring, holding hands. And it just vanished. The Statue of Liberty? Even more amazing. I watched it again with Joe and Joel. And here I'll just narrate for you.
实际上确实让它消失了。人们手拉手围在飞机周围，然后它就真的不见了。自由女神像呢？更不可思议。我和乔、乔尔一起重温了那段视频。现在我来为你们描述。
Imagine it's 1983. You're in the family living room on some couch.
想象现在是1983年，你坐在自家客厅的沙发上。
The TV special opens with helicopter footage of the statue. The illusion happens at night, so it's all lit up. We fly up by the crown, the torch. And then cut to the man himself, David Copperfield, looking like a teen heartthrob-- big, dark eyes, some sort of silvery Rockstar jacket. And this, of course, didn't register with me as a middle school kid, but he's young to be taking on something so ambitious-- 26 years old. He gives this little speech.
特辑开头是自由女神像的直升机航拍。魔术发生在晚上，所以灯火通明。镜头飞向皇冠和火炬，然后切到大卫·科波菲尔本人，看起来像个青春偶像——黑而大的眼睛，穿着一件银色的摇滚夹克。当然，作为一个中学生，我当时没意识到，他年纪轻轻就能挑战如此宏大的工程——才26岁。他发表了一段演讲。
I somehow doubt it happened exactly like that. But whatever. Finally, it's time.
我有点怀疑事实是不是那样发生的。但不管怎样，终于到了时刻。
Copperfield has an audience sitting right there on Liberty Island at the foot of the statue. Everyone is sitting on this stage-- it's outdoors-- looking up at the huge Statue of Liberty, which is about 200 feet away. There are spotlights on it and a helicopter circling overhead. Our view is the same as the audience. We're just behind them, looking up at the statue too. On either side of the stage or two big scaffolding towers, kind of framing the shot. You have a view of the statue between them.
科波菲尔在自由岛女神像脚下安排了一群观众。每个人都坐在户外舞台上，向上仰望离他们约200英尺外巨大的自由女神像。聚光灯照在上面，直升机在头顶盘旋。我们的视角和观众一样，就在他们后面，也看着女神像。舞台两侧是两个巨大的脚手架塔，某种程度上框住了镜头，你可以在它们之间看到女神像。
What happens next is one continuous camera shot-- no visible edits. A giant curtain is hoisted up, suspended between those two scaffolding towers. You can't see the statue now, but it has to be there, right behind the curtain. Then Copperfield puts his left hand to his temple, closes his eyes. This is a signature Copperfield move, familiar to me even now. It's as if he's doing it with his mind. A few seconds pass, the curtain drops. And it's freakin' gone. The statue's gone.
接下来发生的是一个连续的镜头——没有任何明显的编辑痕迹。一块巨大的帷幕升起，悬挂在两座脚手架塔之间。你现在看不见女神像了，但它肯定还在那儿，就在帷幕后面。接着科波菲尔把左手放在太阳穴上，闭上眼睛。这是科波菲尔的标志性动作，即便现在我也很熟悉。感觉他是在用思想驱动。几秒钟过去，帷幕落下。它真的不见了。女神像没了。
The spotlights are there. The helicopters is still circling. But now, circling nothing. Just empty space. The camera cuts to reactions from the audience. Everyone seems astonished. There's one guy wearing a priest collar.
聚光灯还在那里，直升机还在盘旋。但现在，盘旋的是空无一物。镜头切向观众的反应。每个人都显得很震惊，有一个人戴着神职人员的领子。
And then an older woman.
然后是一位老妇人。
Copperfield, I think in an attempt to land some larger meaning, makes a speech about immigrants and how we shouldn't take our liberty for granted. Then he makes the statue reappear. Even Joe Weisberg-- the non-magic fan-- when he finally watched it as an adult, he was moved. For Joel and me as kid magicians, we tried to figure out how he did it.
科波菲尔可能为了提升某种宏大意义，发表了一篇关于移民的演讲，说我们不该把自由视为理所当然。然后他让女神像重新出现。即使是乔·魏斯伯格——那个对魔术没兴趣的人——成年后看到这里也被感动了。对我和乔尔这些曾经的小魔术师来说，我们试图弄清楚他是怎么做到的。
Did you have any theories?
你有过任何猜想吗？
I did not have a good theory. And as somebody who knew a lot of magic gimmicks, I was pretty dumbfounded.
我没想出什么好的理论。作为一个知道很多魔术戏法的人，我当时完全傻了。
Did your friends say, tell me how he did it?
你的朋友们会说：告诉我他是怎么做到的吗？
I'm sure they did. And I think I would have-- I would like to believe that I told them I didn't know.
我肯定他们问过。我希望我当时告诉他们我不知道。
I'm not proud of this, but when kids asked me how Copperfield did it, I have a pretty clear memory of saying something like, sorry, I can't tell you. Which was true-- I couldn't.
我对此并不骄傲，但每当孩子们问我科波菲尔是怎么做到的，我记得很清楚自己会说：抱歉，我不能告诉你们。这是实话——我是真的不知道。
Sometimes, it is not so fun to learn how a trick is done. It's all double lifts and hidden compartments. And when you learn the secret, it can be kind of a letdown. But there are those times when the secret to the trick is cooler than the trick itself-- the sheer ingenuity and genius of it.
有时候，学习魔术的真相并不好玩。全是双张翻牌和暗格。当你学到秘密时，会有点扫兴。但也有时候，魔术背后的秘密比魔术本身更酷——那是纯粹的独创性和天赋。
And so, I'm going to talk now about how this trick might have been done. We thought a lot about whether to put this on the radio. But the truth is you are all a simple Google search away from what I'm about to tell you. That is one of the weird things about magic today over 30 years later-- the internet exists. There's a whole world of explanations and pretty good instructional videos for aspiring magicians.
所以，我现在要谈谈这个魔术可能是怎么做到的。我们纠结过是否在广播里讲这个。但真相是，你们只需要一次简单的谷歌搜索就能找到我要说的内容。这就是30多年后的今天，魔术界最奇怪的一点——互联网存在。有一个充满了关于魔术的解释和相当不错的教学视频的世界。
But if you'd rather not go down this road with me, you can skip ahead or stop listening for about 10 minutes. I totally respect that.
但如果你不想跟我走这条路，你可以跳过或暂停听10分钟。我完全尊重你的选择。
I should also say we did reach out to David Copperfield. And we made a pitch which was basically this may be your greatest hit. It's been 34 years now. Everyone who was going to be fooled by this trick has already been fooled. You'll never perform it again. Nobody's going to perform it again. We're not hurting the livelihood of any magician by revealing the secret. Why not come on the show and talk about what it was like to be on the other side? Copperfield was completely gracious. But he said, it wasn't his job to talk about how the tricks are done. And he said something else. He said, to protect the secrets of his tricks, he's hired people to put fake explanations online, to throw the curious off the track. Which of course, makes the whole thing even more interesting.
我还得说，我们的确联系了大卫·科波菲尔。我们的推销词大致是：这可能是你的巅峰之作。已经34年了，所有会被这个魔术戏弄的人都已经戏弄过了。你永远不会再表演它了，也没人会再表演了。揭露这个秘密不会伤害任何魔术师的生计。为什么不来节目聊聊站在幕后的感受呢？科波菲尔非常客气。但他表示，谈论魔术是如何完成的不是他的工作。他还说了另一件事：为了保护秘密，他雇了人把虚假的解释放到网上，以此误导好奇的人。当然，这让整件事变得更有趣了。
So here is the explanation that is on the internet, and also in one book written by a non-magician-- instead of moving the statue, Copperfield moved the audience. The entire audience. Rotated them, actually. They were sitting unknowingly on a giant rotating platform. Think a huge lazy Susan.
所以，这是互联网上的解释，也出现在一本由非魔术师写的书里：科波菲尔没有移动女神像，他移动的是观众。整个观众席。实际上是旋转了他们。他们当时不知不觉地坐在一个巨大的旋转平台上。想象一个巨大的“懒人苏珊”（旋转餐台）。
So here's how it would have worked-- the curtain gets hoisted up between the two towers, blocking the statue from view. And while it's up, the platform, with the entire audience on it and the giant scaffolding towers and the curtain, the whole thing rotates until it's facing away from the statue. So that when the curtain falls, the audience is looking out at nothing. Or, I think, to be precise, they're looking out at part of the New Jersey coastline.
事情是这样运作的：帷幕在两座塔之间升起，挡住了女神像的视线。当帷幕升起时，载着整个观众席、脚手架塔和帷幕的平台，整体旋转到背对女神像的位置。所以当帷幕落下时，观众面对的是虚空。或者说，准确点，他们面对的是新泽西海岸线的一部分。
It's such a beautiful secret-- smart and simple and big.
这是个多么美丽的秘密啊——聪明、简单而宏大。
There is another part of the secret, which is even cooler. When I first heard there might have been a rotating platform, I wondered, what was to stop the audience members from just turning their heads and seeing the statue? After all, it should have been just off to one side. The answer? It's hidden, in what, in retrospect, is the only possible place-- behind one of the scaffolding towers used to hold the curtain up. The scaffolding tower is tiny compared to the statue. But it's close enough to the audience that with the platform rotated to just the right position, the tower blocks the statue from view.
还有这个秘密的另一部分，甚至更酷。当我第一次听说可能有一个旋转平台时，我纳闷，是什么阻止了观众转过头去看见女神像呢？毕竟，它应该就在侧面。答案藏在回顾起来唯一的可能之处——挡住观众视线的那个脚手架塔后。脚手架塔比女神像小得多，但它离观众够近，只要平台旋转到正确的角度，塔就能挡住女神像。
Watching the TV special again knowing this made it even more impressive. I kept thinking, how exciting and nerve-wracking it must have been to be Copperfield in that moment. To pull this off, the rotation would have been fast enough that it didn't seem to take too long, but not so fast that someone would notice. And super smooth. Here's Joel Fields, former kid magician.
在知道这一点后重看这个特辑，让它变得更让人印象深刻了。我不停地想，那一刻作为科波菲尔该有多刺激、多紧张。要完成这个，旋转速度必须快到让人感觉不到，但又不能快到让人注意到。而且要超级平滑。这是当年的小魔术师乔尔·菲尔兹的感受。
First of all, how could the people there not have noticed? It's like high stakes, right? It's ballsy. To put these people on a thing, and like, hope that really no one's going to notice. It's a wildly gutsy trick.
首先，那儿的人怎么可能没注意到？这 stakes（赌注）很高，对吧？很大胆。让这些人坐在上面，寄希望于真的没人会注意到。这是一个极其大胆的魔术。
Well, why? Could it have not worked? What could have gone wrong?
为什么？它有可能会失败吗？可能会出什么差错？
One or more people could have said, hey, this platform's rotating. Someone could have had a compass.
一个人或更多人可能会说：嘿，平台在旋转。可能会有人带了指南针。
The more I thought about this, the more questions I had. Was this really how it was done? Could you get away with something like that? Maybe this was a fake explanation, planted by David Copperfield. A scaffolding tower to hide some deeper secret.
我想得越多，疑问就越多。这真的是这样完成的吗？你能蒙混过关吗？也许这是一个假解释，是大卫·科波菲尔植入的，用一个脚手架塔来掩盖更深的秘密。
I figured the best thing would be to track down some of the audience members who were there at the foot of the Statue of Liberty. But remember, this happened in 1983. And in any case, none of the audience members are named. I didn't see any easy way to track them down. But as I was watching and re-watching the video of the trick, I found one shot where someone's name was revealed, someone I could try to contact. It comes in the lead up, where Copperfield is in the office of the Park Service official for the Statue of Liberty. It's just a quick cutaway where he's explaining that he had to get permission to make the statue disappear. But if you freeze frame on that part, you can just make out, on the man's desk, a name plate-- David L Moffitt.
我想最好的办法就是找到当时在自由女神像脚下的观众。但记住，这是1983年。而且无论如何，观众都没有姓名。我没找到轻易联系他们的方法。但在反复观看录像时，我发现了一个镜头，画面里揭露了一个名字，一个我可以尝试联系的人。在铺垫阶段，科波菲尔在自由女神像公园管理局官员的办公室里。镜头只切了一下，解释他必须获得许可才能让女神像消失。但如果你暂停那个部分，你可以勉强看清办公桌上的名牌——大卫·L·莫菲特（David L Moffitt）。
I had no idea if this guy was still alive. This was, after all, 34 years ago. But I started searching for a David L Moffitt. And I found one-- in Virginia, but with a previous residence of Liberty Island.
我不知道这家伙还在不在世。毕竟那可是34年前。但我开始搜寻大卫·L·莫菲特，我找到了一个——在弗吉尼亚州，但有在自由岛居住的记录。
Hi!
你好！
I got on a plane to fly down there.
我搭上了去那里的飞机。
--recognized automatically, my driveway's a killer. Sit down and relax.
——自动认出，我的车道真是个坑。请坐下放松。
For 10 years, if you wanted to do anything with the Statue of Liberty, you had to go through David L Moffittt. He lived on the little island with his family. The Park Service has a house there. The statue was right outside his window. He felt like it was his job to protect her.
十年来，如果你想对自由女神像做任何事，你都得经过大卫·L·莫菲特。他和家人住在那个小岛上，公园管理局在那儿有房子。女神像就在他窗外。他觉得保护它是他的职责。
It was also a member of the family.
这也是家庭成员之一。
When a deodorant maker tried to use her in an ad, maybe because she has her arm up, David Moffittt fought back. When a furniture company wanted to hang a couch from her and have someone sit in the couch, he vetoed it. And when David Copperfield requested permission to make her disappear, he said no.
当一家除臭剂制造商试图在广告里使用她时，也许是因为她举着手臂，大卫·莫菲特进行了反击。当一家家具公司想把沙发挂在她身上让人坐时，他否决了。当大卫·科波菲尔请求准许让她消失时，他说不。
I personally felt that was inappropriate use of such a sacred icon. And I wrote back a rejection to the request. And I thought that probably was the end of it.
我个人觉得那是对这样一个神圣偶像的不当使用。我写了一封拒绝信。我以为这事就这么结束了。
But a couple of weeks later, Moffitt gets a letter in the mail from the director of the National Park Service, giving Copperfield permission. Copperfield had gone over his head. He had connections in the White House. Copperfield's team did confirm this. They said he got permission directly from Ronald Reagan.
但几周后，莫菲特收到国家公园管理局局长的来信，给了科波菲尔许可。科波菲尔越过了他。他在白宫有关系。科波菲尔的团队证实了这一点。他们说他是直接从罗纳德·里根那里得到的许可。
To put it mildly, I was a little bit taken back. A few days later, I walked in my office, and there's David Copperfield. He's standing up there. Very handsome, nice looking guy, well-dressed.
委婉地说，我当时有点被冒犯了。几天后，我走进办公室，大卫·科波菲尔就在那儿。他站在那儿，非常英俊，面孔迷人，衣着考究。
Copperfield apologized for getting him overruled. Moffitt says Copperfield seemed sincere, like a nice guy.
科波菲尔为让他被越权道歉了。莫菲特说科波菲尔看起来很真诚，是个好人。
I signed a permit. And then he says that I would like for you to sign a waiver that you will not disclose how I'll make the statue disappear. I said no, I won't do that. I said I would never do anything that would limit my freedom of speech.
我签署了一份许可。然后他说，我想让你签一份豁免书，声明你不会泄露我是如何让女神像消失的。我说不，我不会那么做。我说我绝不会做任何限制我言论自由的事。
Hard to argue with that while you're at the foot of the Statue of Liberty. Moffitt was there during the filming, and he saw how the trick was done. He says he kept his mouth shut for the last three decades. Only told family and a few friends. But he confirmed for me, the explanation on the internet, that is the real explanation. He even demonstrated for me.
在自由女神像脚下反驳这种要求是很难的。莫菲特在拍摄期间就在现场，他看到了魔术是如何完成的。他说这三十年来他守口如瓶，只告诉了家人和几个朋友。但他向我证实了互联网上的解释就是真实的。他甚至为我演示了。
We got the lazy Susan that I use for pottery. That thing. Could you get that? Or I'll get it.
我们拿到了我做陶艺用的“懒人苏珊”。那个东西。你能拿来吗？或者我去拿。
He had a miniature Statue of Liberty, of course.
当然，他有一个缩微版的自由女神像。
Its stage starts turning. And it goes maybe 25 or 30 degrees to the right.
舞台开始转动。它向右转了大约25或30度。
During the filming, Moffitt was standing just off to the side of the platform. I found another guy who was there, and who confirmed the basic mechanics of how the trick was done. But talking to him made me wonder if there might be a whole other level of deception to the trick. His name is Al Cerullo. His name was in the credits for the show. He flew a helicopter in the Vietnam War. And now, for TV and movies. So many. The Avengers, Spiderman, Muppets Take Manhattan.
拍摄过程中，莫菲特就站在平台边。我找到了另一个当时在场的人，他也证实了这个魔术的基本机械原理。但和他交谈让我怀疑，这个魔术背后是否还有更深层次的欺骗。他的名字是阿尔·塞鲁洛（Al Cerullo）。他的名字在节目的工作人员名单里。他在越战中开过直升机，现在是电影制作人。很多电影：《复仇者联盟》、《蜘蛛侠》、《布偶大闹曼哈顿》。
The one I want to ask you about was in the 1980s.
我想问你的那个发生在80年代。
That would be probably Turk 182 or one of those movies?
那可能是《土耳其182》（Turk 182）或者类似的电影之一？
It was in 1983.
那是1983年。
Not Nighthawks?
不是《夜鹰》（Nighthawks）？
It involved the Statue of Liberty.
它涉及自由女神像。
Oh, Working Girl.
噢，《上班女郎》（Working Girl）。
[LAUGHS] No, when David Copperfield made the Statue of--
[笑声] 不，是当大卫·科波菲尔让自由女神像……
Oh, David Copperfield! Yeah. Yeah, that was a pretty big deal, actually.
噢，大卫·科波菲尔！是啊。是啊，那当时是个大新闻。
He told me the helicopter's job was to fly from position A to position B while the curtain was blocking the view. Basically from above the statue to above a designated empty spot, which was rigged with duplicate spotlights. If you think about it, the helicopter and the lights are the fixed points in the trick-- the things that make the audience think they're looking at the same spot.
他告诉我，直升机的工作是在帷幕遮住视线时，从A点飞到B点。基本上是从女神像上方飞到预定的空地，那儿 rigged（安装）了重复的聚光灯。如果你仔细想想，直升机和灯光是这个魔术中的固定点——也就是让观众认为他们依然在盯着同一个地方的东西。
I didn't think he was going to be able to pull it off.
我当时觉得他不可能成功。
How come? Like, what were you worried about happening?
怎么说？你担心会发生什么？
You know, the stage-- you'd feel the stage moving or whatever. They spent a lot of money, evidently, on some kind of bearings in the stage. You know? On the bottom, so that you wouldn't feel it. It got delayed a couple of times because it wasn't working right. Couldn't get it to work the way you wanted.
你知道的，舞台——你会感觉到舞台在动什么的。他们显然在舞台的轴承上花了很多钱。你懂吗？在底部，这样你就感觉不到它在动。它被延期了好几次，因为它运转不正常。搞不到他们想要的效果。
Which put this unpleasant thought in my head-- was the audience really fooled by this? Or were they maybe in on it the whole time?
这让我的头脑里产生了一个令人不快的念头：观众真的被骗了吗？还是他们其实从一开始就是托儿？
Yes.
是的。
Is that right?
是吗？
Yeah. That's-- yes. Some of the people in the audience were staged. They knew what was going to happen.
是啊。就是——是的。观众席里有些人是事先安排好的。他们知道会发生什么。
Oh.
噢。
Not everybody. I don't think so.
不是所有人。我不这么认为。
Do you know?
你知道吗？
No, I don't know about that part of it. We never got into that. I never asked him, he never mentioned it. You know?
不，我不清楚那部分。我们没深入聊过。我从没问过他，他也没提过。你懂吗？
I asked David L Moffitt, the Park Service guy. Was the audience in on it? He answered with a story. This happened just after they finished shooting.
我问了大卫·L·莫菲特，那个公园管理局的人。观众是托儿吗？他用一个故事回答了。这发生在他们拍完之后。
Everybody was slapping everybody on the back. And everybody a hap, you know. And I said something to one of the so-called audience-- how did you end up here? And she said, oh, I was paid for this.
每个人都在互相拍背，大家都很高兴。我问了其中一个所谓的观众：你怎么会来这儿的？她说，噢，我是拿钱来的。
I was paid to come here?
我是拿钱来这儿的？
Yeah. And that was kind of the end of the conversation. I was-- I didn't-- that's not what-- I wasn't investigating. I was just curious where these people came from. Especially when they acted so amazed that it had disappeared. Because they felt the stage moving. They couldn't help but feel the stage moving.
是啊。对话就在那儿结束了。我……我没有……这不是我……我当时没在调查，只是好奇这些人是从哪儿来的。特别是当他们表现出女神像消失时那么震惊的时候。因为他们感觉到了舞台在动，他们不可能感觉不到舞台在动。
Do you think they were all actors?
你认为他们全是演员吗？
I don't know if they were actors or wannabe ac-- I don't know. I know that one of them was paid to be there.
我不知道他们是演员还是想当演员的人……我不清楚。我知道其中一个确实是拿钱来的。
Moffitt went back over this in his memory, because he wanted to be accurate. He later told us he thinks it was one of his employees who talked to the woman. To be fair, it's been over 30 years.
莫菲特回想了一下这段记忆，因为他想准确。他后来告诉我们，他认为是他的一名员工跟那个女人谈过话。公平地说，那已经是30多年前的事了。
But this thought, that the audience might have been in on it, it made me incredibly sad. It felt like cheating. If all those people going wow, they were paid to go wow, they weren't fooled? That's not magic. That's like we're watching a play about magic. I told the Americans producers Joe and Joel about this. Joel, the former kid magician, didn't see it the way I did. At all.
但这个念头——观众可能是托儿——让我感到极其悲伤。这感觉像作弊。如果所有那些惊叹的“哇”的人都是付钱买来的，他们根本没被骗？那不是魔术，那就像我们在看一出关于魔术的戏剧。我把这个告诉了《美国谍梦》的制片人乔和乔尔。乔尔，那个曾经的小魔术师，一点也没像我这么想。完全没有。
It means he bought off the whole audience.
这意味着他收买了整个观众席。
No. No! No, it doesn't.
不。不！不，不是。
It might mean that.
可能是那样。
It doesn't. Let's say he-- no. The audience was us. The television audience is the audience. He promised to make the Statue of Liberty disappear with no camera tricks. He made the Statue of Liberty disappear with no camera tricks. It's pretty dramatic. And it was moving.
不是。假设他……不。观众是我们。电视观众才是观众。他承诺在没有摄像机特技的情况下让女神像消失。他在没有摄像机特技的情况下让女神像消失了。这非常有戏剧性，而且很感人。
I think it's a little troubling. If true.
我觉得这有点令人不安。如果属实的话。
If true.
如果属实的话。
I honestly didn't know what to believe. I watched the TV special again and again. And some of the audience members started to look like actors. At least in moments. Like just after the curtain drops and the statue is gone, this one guy leans over to the woman next to him and points in this kind of hokey way. Then there's the fact that one of the audience members is in a priest collar. Really? You happened to get a priest in the audience? And do priests dress that way when they go out at night?
我真的不知道该相信什么。我一遍又一遍地看电视特辑。其中一些观众看起来确实像演员，至少在某些时刻。比如帷幕落下、女神像消失后，那个男人向身边的女人靠过去，指着那边，动作显得很做作。还有观众里有一个人穿着神职人员领子，真的吗？你碰巧观众席里就有个牧师？而且牧师晚上出门是那样穿吗？
Finally, I got a tip. I was at this magic show talking to these two people. One of them I'll call a former high ranking official in the magic establishment. They knew someone who had been there on Liberty Island during the filming of the show and would know the truth. I called the person up, and he agreed to talk.
最后，我得到了个线索。我在一个魔术秀上和两个人交谈。其中一个人我会称之为魔术界的某位前高层人士。他们认识一个在拍摄期间在自由岛现场的人，他会知道真相。我打了电话，他同意谈谈。
My name is Ed Alonzo. I'm known as the misfit of magic. And maybe you remember me as Max, the owner of the diner on Saved By The Bell.
我是艾德·阿隆佐（Ed Alonzo）。我是魔术界的“怪胎”。也许你记得我在《救命下课铃》（Saved By The Bell）里演过那个餐馆老板“马克斯”。
Ed was also the guy who made that curtain go up and down in front of the Statue of Liberty. Actually, there were two guys. It was a big curtain. Ed was 18 years old at the time, a young magician. Says he stayed overnight at David Copperfield's parents' house in New Jersey before the shoot. I told him I'd heard the audience might have been in on it. I told him what the Park Service guy had told me. That an audience member had said she had been paid to be there.
艾德也是那个在自由女神像前拉帷幕的人。实际上有两个，那是个巨大的帷幕。艾德当时18岁，是个年轻魔术师。他说拍摄前一天晚上他住在新泽西大卫·科波菲尔父母的家里。我告诉他我听说观众可能是托儿，告诉了他公园管理局那个人说的话——有个观众说她拿了钱。
Really? See, I'm totally surprised. It is possible that maybe some of the people were paid to be there only because they couldn't get enough regular people with the amount of tickets that they gave out.
真的？看，我完全惊讶了。可能只有很少一部分人是拿了钱的，只是因为给出的票不够多，凑不够正儿八经的普通人。
Sometimes you do use paid extras in an audience, he says. They show up on time. And you can tell them to dress nicely.
他说，有时你确实会用付费临时演员。他们准时到场，而且你可以告诉他们穿好看点。
But even if they were paid people, they would have not known how the trick was done. There was no reason for anyone to know ahead of time.
但即便他们是付费的人，他们也不会知道魔术是怎么做到的。没理由让任何人提前知道。
Copperfield's team, by the way, says no audience members were paid. They say the woman who claims she was paid to be there must have been on the production staff. And Ed says an enormous amount of work was done to make sure the trick would fool people. Ed didn't want to talk about or confirm the mechanics of the trick. But he said they did a whole dry run beforehand out in Los Angeles.
顺便说一句，科波菲尔的团队说没有付费观众。他们说那个自称拿钱的人一定是制作组成员。艾德说他们做了大量工作来确保魔术能骗过人们。艾德不想谈论或证实魔术的技巧，但他表示他们在洛杉矶之前做了全套演练。
The idea to make the Statue of Liberty disappear came from an illusion designer named Jim Steinmeyer. Copperfield's team, with the help of a guy named Don Wayne, added all kinds of improvements and built the stage. As a test, they used it to make the moon disappear. They set the stage up basically in this parking lot.
让女神像消失的创意来自幻术设计师吉姆·斯坦迈耶（Jim Steinmeyer）。科波菲尔团队在唐·韦恩（Don Wayne）的帮助下加入各种改进并搭建了舞台。为了测试，他们用它让月亮消失。他们基本上是在停车场搭的舞台。
Yeah, we were in a parking lot. Because the stage was enormous. David thought that we have to do kind of a demonstration to work out the bugs before we haul this thing to New York.
是的，我们在停车场。因为舞台太庞大了。大卫觉得我们得做一个演示，在把这玩意拖到纽约之前解决Bug。
A bunch of top magicians in LA sat on the stage. Copperfield made the moon disappear. And everyone gave notes. Tweaks to make it better, so you could fool a real audience. Ed says the night of the filming at the Statue of Liberty, it was clear to him that the people in the audience were fooled. I asked him why in a couple of shots the audience seemed a little fake to me. He had a pretty good explanation, which is that they filmed the trick multiple times. Copperfield's team officially denies this. Ed says it's so, though.
洛杉矶的一群顶尖魔术师坐在舞台上。科波菲尔让月亮消失了。每个人都提了意见。为了能骗过真实的观众，要不断修改完善。艾德说拍摄那天在自由女神像现场，他很清楚观众是被骗住了。我问他为什么在几个镜头里观众看起来有点假。他给了一个很好的解释：因为他们排练了好多次。科波菲尔官方否认这一点，但艾德说这是真的。
I think that maybe after we did it about the third or fourth time, some of the people that were sitting on this platform may have had an idea as to what was going on.
我觉得也许在我们演了第三次或第四次后，坐在平台上的有些人可能已经看出点门道了。
I grilled Ed for an hour about this. And for what it's worth, I believe him when he says the audience was not in on it. Though I do have this tiny sliver of doubt. Which I have to say, I kind of enjoy the feeling of.
我就此盘问了艾德一小时。对于他说的观众不是托儿这点，我是相信的。虽然我心里仍有那一点点的怀疑，但我必须说，我挺享受那种感觉的。
David Copperfield told us he was disappointed that we wanted to do our story on a trick that's over 30 years old. He said he had better stuff now, stuff he had just invented that he's totally jazzed about. You need to see it, he said. So Ira and I went to a show in Las Vegas. Copperfield is 60 years old now and doing two or three shows a day. That's just how he rolls. The other year, he did over 600 performances.
大卫·科波菲尔说，他对我们执意要做一个30多年前魔术的报道感到失望。他说他现在有更好的东西，刚发明出来的，他非常兴奋。你需要看看，他说。所以我和艾拉去拉斯维加斯看了演出。科波菲尔今年60岁了，一天演两三场。这就是他的节奏。去年一年，他演了600多场。
The show is not all to my taste, but it was amazing. The work of an obsessive person, driven to keep creating new things. At one point, the lights went out, just for a brief moment. And when they came back on, an enormous flying saucer had appeared, right over our heads. I mean, huge. It took up a good part of the theater. And it moved like the Millennium Falcon or something, hovering and banking-- the way you imagine flying saucers moving when you were a kid. It was this moment of sheer surprise and delight and joy. I don't care how he did it.
演出并不全符合我的审美，但它很棒。这是一个强迫症患者的作品，驱动着他不断创造新事物。某一刻，灯光暗了片刻。当灯光恢复时，一个巨大的飞碟出现在我们头顶。我是说，巨大。它占据了剧院的一大部分。它像《千年隼》一样移动，悬浮、倾斜——和你小时候想象飞碟移动的方式一模一样。那是纯粹的惊喜、喜悦和欢乐的时刻。我才不管他是怎么做到的。
David Kestenbaum.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
It's me using leverage and slack and all sorts of things like that.
是我利用了杠杆、线的松弛度以及各种类似的技巧。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。